if somebody is starting from scratch
what are the traits skill sets that they
should be cultivating in order to up the
odds of their success they should focus
on one thing in general rather than lots
of different things that you're not sure
about because if you're starting out
everything looks like an opportunity so
correct answer is all of them are
opportunities but all of them won't work
unless you pick one so boom you pick one
and then from there I always say six
figures is sell something to someone
that's it and if you want more detail
sell something to someone so it's one
Avatar one product one channel you don't
have to figure out just pick one channel
one media Source whether it's Facebook
Instagram YouTube consistently start
going on that whether that's cold
outbound whether that's content whatever
it is and start reaching out to people
there to start selling your stuff you
have to learn how to advertise which I
Define is the process of making now so
you have to advertise there's six ways
to do it and then once people engage
with whatever advertisement you have
advertising is the first skill selling
and it's the second skill product would
be the third skill which is the thing
that you're ultimately advertising in
selling baggage is six figures what gets
the seven doing the same thing
consistently so usually once people do
it in the beginning they're sporadic
they're not consistent with it usually
gets people to 100 000 a month it's
crazy it's probably people listening but
most people who think that's crazy also
haven't done it consistently for an
extended period of time and so I use
something that I call the rule 100 which
is 100 primary actions whether that's
100 minutes of content creation per day
100 reach outs per day you have to pick
one of them but 100 per day you do that
for 100 days and I promise you'll be
making six figures if you do that you
wake up tomorrow morning and you're on
the street and you have nothing you
don't have a single contact in your
network all you have is the knowledge
and experience that you've had
throughout your career how do you build
up from there if I had to do it again
I'd go work at McDonald's and the reason
I go work for McDonald's you know
whether it's seven bucks an hour or 15.
I don't really care they have the best
Business Systems in the world so right
inside little McDonald's you can learn
everything you need to learn about
business except for the management side
I spend most of my time with
entrepreneurs I don't spend my time with
people who complain about the economy so
that didn't really change I just go back
to being an entrepreneur entrepreneurs
have one thing in common they keep going
they'll change the rules they'll
reinvent the rules you know they don't
just take one answer so a real
entrepreneur really makes no difference
which country you're in you know I have
a friend from France he started buying
vineyards in Napa and Sonoma so he went
back to the French government he says I
want to ship my wine in bulk to
California and the government says you
can't do that he says okay I can't ship
him in barrels a guy goes yeah he says
okay I'll ship it in bottles but he's
still figured out how to do it his wine
with his California wine and all this
and so he went back to the French
conference here try this see if it's not
better and so now they're all confused
because he didn't break any rules so
I'll say it again entrepreneur is a
mindset first a skill set and rules
one of the things you would want to be
sure to do is whether you like it or not
get very comfortable with public
speaking for example I mean let's say an
asset that will last you 50 or 60 years
and it's a liability if you don't like
doing it or uncomfortable doing it it's
a necessary skill one of the big things
that all startups do is they lie to
themselves mine's faster mine's cheaper
mine's better no it's not and the reason
it's not is because whoever it is you're
competing with it's not like they're
ignoring you it's not like oh my
goodness this guy just started on
Shopify and the startup competition he's
doing a million dollars this year what
are they doing I'm going to copy what
they're doing and now you've got to stay
ahead you know you've got to be very
careful as an entrepreneur to be
brutally honest with yourself and those
are some of the things that you'll hear
from me as a mentor that you know know
what you know know what you don't know
but you've got to know your business
better than anybody something I
encourage a lot of entrepreneurs to
think about I think a lot of people they
will go from their full-time job quit
they have very meager savings and
suddenly they're like this has to work
well now you've put yourself in a bad
position either start it while you have
a full-time job do it on the side and
don't tell me you don't have time you
have time and the second thing is build
up your savings your savings are going
to give you the runway or the
flexibility to try different things a
business is not easy especially going
from zero to one it's pretty hard and if
you're under a time crunch where you
have like two months of cash left you're
gonna start making bad decisions also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free work cheat
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all of the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there I worked at McDonald's I got fired
I worked at a furniture store I got
fired I worked in a car dealership I was
fired six times from the same guy and
I've been fired so many times I finally
figured out how to get fired and keep my
job I'm a sales guy because not because
I wanted to that was not something I
wanted to do my dad told my mom before
he died tell those boys to learn how to
sell he knew he was going to die and
he's like tell those boys to learn how
to sell and they can go anywhere my mom
didn't tell me that until I was like 25
26 years old and I had to take a sales
job she she wanted me to be a more a
professional so I went and got an
accounting degree got out of college
there was 25 unemployment I didn't know
it I didn't go to college and become a
Salesman but it was the only job I could
get when I was 25 years old it was be
unemployed or take this job selling
Toyotas I didn't even know what a Toyota
was so I took this job that I did I
thought it was just going to be a
temporary job I said okay I'm gonna do
this for until I can get a real job and
that ended up becoming my career I
actually hated sales because all the
jobs I had outside of McDonald's were
part-time sales jobs I sold clothes no
money that you have is not the issue it
doesn't actually take money to make
money it takes courage to make money it
takes contacts to make money money is a
contact sport I need to make contact
with people okay it's not about skills
it's not about education it's not about
personality it's about context the more
contacts I make the more chances I have
somebody asked me recently said hey
would you rather a billion friends or a
billion dollars I said dude give me a
billion friends billion friends is worth
at least five or ten billion dollars a
billion dollars is only a billion
dollars and if I can actually go make
contact with a billion people and get
them to trade money with me just five
percent of those people just five
percent of those people gave me a
hundred dollars because I traded some
service that was worth a thousand I'd be
worth five billion dollars so you see
most people don't understand the math
the money money is not about numbers
money is about people somebody that
wants to completely transform who they
are you have to change your identity I'm
the smart guy and that's how I thought
of myself and then the life slapped me
around and I realized oh wow I'm really
actually not that smart I just grew up
in a small town I realized that I had
been sort of taken as a default value
intelligence maybe it was the family I
grew up in or the movies I watched I
don't know and then I realized oh I can
actually change that not everybody
values themselves for that and so I
could swap that out with something else
I want people to understand that those
things that are just deeply within you
that seem as if they are innate human
qualities challenge them all a lot of
what you value comes down to what you
repeat and so just repeating myself I'm
the learner I'm the learner I'm the
learner it began to be my identity and
then rewarding myself emotionally when I
did that then it's like through that
repetition cycle it actually starts to
be meaningful that you're the learner
and by the way I was telling everybody
I'm the learner I see myself as a
learner I'm the learner I'm the learner
and because I was telling people then I
really felt the sense of congruence with
wanting to act like the learner and so
when you say you're going to do
something and you do it you earn
self-credibility so now I've got this
Loop going I said I was a learner here I
am reading this book here I am being
willing to admit when I'm wrong seeking
out knowledge looking for disconfirming
evidence like I get to feel good about
myself for that one hour more per day on
my core three I begin this every year
first move I need to identify what are
the core three things right now that
have been bringing me results this year
the core three things so as an example
in my business I go okay what are the
three primary revenue drivers we have
right now because just like you if
you're in marketing you've probably
tested a lot of things throughout the
early part of the year the spring even
in early part of summer so my question
is what's been working and I mean
absolutely working what are the three
absolute best things they're working for
you in your business or your career or
your personal life if you're not
employed or not self-employed what's
with the three things that are so
working for you I want you to know what
those three things are and overall I
want you to give an hour every day more
to a focus of one two or three all three
of those things there's a great story of
two Lumberjacks where every morning they
start chopping wood at the same time and
every day they stop chopping wood at the
same time and every day one of The
Lumberjacks disappears for about an hour
in the middle of the day and every day
he chops more wood than the other guy
and this goes on for months and
eventually the one who works all day
says I don't understand every day we
start at the same time every day we stop
at the same time every day you disappear
for about an hour in the middle of the
day and every day you Chuck more wood
than me where do you go for that hour
and the other Lumberjack looks up and
goes oh I'll go home and sharpen my ax
if you take an infinite mindset it's not
about how much you can get done each day
it's how much you can get done over the
course of a career over the course of a
lifetime you gotta take vacations which
means you turn off your email and you
turn off your phone and you do not
connect to the office go sharpen your
act take a Friday afternoon off we have
something called duvet days in our
company where you wake up in the morning
and you just can't do it it's not like
vacation days where you plan ahead and
it's not like sick days like you're not
sick you just don't want to do it and
it's not feeling it you can't do it and
you do responsibly you can't leave your
team in the Lurch obviously you have to
exercise responsible freedom but we give
people an opportunity instead of lying
and pretending that they have a stomach
bug because they just can't face the day
that they can just call up and say I'm
taking a duvet day and everybody goes go
go we got you you know go don't make a
plan that is what you should do make a
plan that outlines a future so that you
can sit back and say look if I had that
future then all the horrible things that
are going to happen to me are going to
be worthwhile that's what you want if
you want to think this game is worth
playing despite its tragedy that's what
you've got in life enough meaning to
serve as an antidote to tragedy and then
you generate a strategy the other thing
you should do if you're not very
industrious is discipline yourself eat
three times a day at regular meal times
that's a good thing to practice because
that starts to put some stability into
your life get up at the same time I
would highly recommend all those young
people out there who are listening you
want to get a jump on life get the hell
out of bed in the morning as I've got
older I've got up earlier and earlier
now that's partly because you don't need
as much sleep but it's also partly
because I've got more and more
discipline get up early in the morning
and get your things done learn to get up
at six in the morning and you'll be one
deadly creature especially if you can
get to work you'll have half your damn
day done and so that's a massive massive
advantage
how do I make this a six figure business
what do I prioritize so you're targeting
the people who like can't afford a
bookkeeper yet but are making mistakes
themselves and don't know what to do
when you're like frustrated with the
software and like maybe you feel
overwhelmed by the numbers and
everything else yeah the problem with
that is in terms of getting a mid six
figure business you need such scale
because those people don't have money so
the fastest way to get to Mid six
figures is solve a big problem for
people with money because you need fewer
people so it's not that that can't work
you just need a lot more people to be
able to get it to Mid six figures the
mission is so much bigger than working
with 10 clients or 20 clients but when
you're making mid six figures that
allows you a lot more freedom to then
make content at scale even if you never
get paid for it because I know your
heart your passion is to help the
content becomes free that can help
everybody all of the new customers but
you need money to pay for all of that so
if you're making mid six figures in your
business then you can do whatever you
want on the content side of things most
of this generation quits the second they
get talked to you did this wrong you did
this wrong it's so easy to be great
nowadays most people are weak this is a
softened generation so if you have any
mental toughness any ability if you have
any fraction of self-discipline the
ability to not want to do it but still
do it people have a hard thing to
understand I hate to run and what makes
me so crazy people well why do you run
if you hate it what are you talking
about I don't want to take showers and
eat either I hate that too that's a life
man it wasn't until I changed that
mentality that I became somebody I hated
going to school so guess what I was
dumbest one plus one is two but if you
can get through to doing things that you
hate to do on the other side is
greatness that's what people understand
by me running I am callous in my mind
I'm not training for a race I'm training
for life I'm training for the time when
I get that two o'clock in the morning
call that my mom is dead or something
happens tragic in life I don't fall
apart do it anyway is a mindset trick
that you can use when you start to feel
excuses rolling up it works a lot like
the five second rule you have said to
yourself okay I'm going to talk to my
boss today about that thing that I've
been avoiding talking to them about and
then the moment comes where you've got
to have that conversation or the moment
comes where it's time to pack up your
bag and leave your desk and go to the
gym and what always happens you don't
feel like it I bet there are plenty of
you watching that have made a commitment
that I'm not going to have a drink
tonight and then guess what happens when
you get home you don't feel like not
drinking you feel like having a drink
here's what do it anyway has done for me
the idea that I just do it anyway has
pushed me to realize and to recognize
that there are a lot of moments when
there are things in my life that I
really want to do I need to do but when
the moment comes I don't feel like it
and so I pull out this idea of you know
what I'm just gonna do it anyway it's
raining outside I said I would go for a
short run I don't feel like it I'm gonna
do it anyway it's six o'clock in the
morning I'm tired it's cold I laid out
my yoga clothes but now I don't feel
like it what do I do I do it anyway when
you start to say to yourself I'm gonna
do it anyway what happens is something
really cool you acknowledge that there
are feelings that you have that are
trying to swoop in and hijack you and
you basically say guess what I'm gonna
do it anyway
an addiction to distraction is the death
of your creative production and we all
know about the dopamine addiction that
happens when you play with your phone
and so every time we look for like every
time we play with a phone every time we
respond to a notification there's a shot
of dopamine that creates a habit and
then over time the Habit turns into an
addiction that is just as powerful as an
addiction to cocaine there's a concept
known as attention residue and every
single time you respond to a
notification every single time you look
at your phone you deliver or give a
piece of your Priceless attention to
that notification and if you do it a
hundred times a day then by the end of
the day you have zero Focus I was in a
high quality Hotel relatively recently
and I ordered a large bottle of Evian
water and I kid you not they delivered
11 bottles of Evian water you want to
talk about the mistakes being made it is
stunning there are very few people who
are fully present and yet one of the
traits of the great Geniuses is is this
they could spend law long stretches of
time in acute Focus thinking about one
project free of distraction and then in
the book I talked about the model it's
called transient hypofrontality which is
really Flow State we all can tap into
Flow State where genius lives but you
don't get to do there if you're checking
your phone all day long I think the best
way to prove your your value is to work
is to learn is to absorb to be a sponge
you always want to outwork your
potential you know as hard as you
believe you can work you can work harder
than that and that's what I tried to do
when I first came in a league but you
know basketball is such a direct
competition Sport and me coming in at 17
I hated when like my teammates would say
you know I get hit with an elbow right
Shaq with it and go to elbow in practice
always had that extra chip on my
shoulder so like every day in practice
for me was really trying to annihilate
everybody that was that I was playing
against I wanted to prove you don't need
to babysit me and so it's always that
competitive nature the work ethic and
curiosity My Philosophy was a very
simple one Rudy was one of my favorite
films growing up after watching that
film I come to understand if I could
work that hard with my career be and I
made a promise to myself from that day
that I was going to work that hard every
single day so that when I do retire I
have no regrets and that was the most
important thing for me is to leave no
stone unturned get better every single
day and if I live that way then over
time you know I'd have something that
was beautiful that was my philosophy it
seems like a pretty simple one but you
know if you live your life to just get
better every single day and do that for
20 years I mean what do you have what do
you think is the greatest human skill
not habit but mindset and skill I think
the ability to manage your own mind and
emotions is probably one of the single
most important and maybe the second is
the ability to influence others that's
what makes you a leader and hopefully
you're doing that for a higher good
because there are all kinds of leaders
as you know I don't think most people
are very good at emotional Fitness most
people are just not as happy as they
could be and I did one book money Master
the game it's kind of like this well
only what I did in that case is I
interviewed 50 of the smartest Financial
people play dalio Carl icon Warren
Buffett and out of 50 of them and I
spent a lot of time with them some have
become really good friends there's
probably four or five that are really
happy people oh well money makes people
unhappy you know money has nothing to do
with money money makes you more of what
you are just magnifies if you're mean
you have more to be mean if you're kind
you have more to give you know but I
think that most people are just they
haven't learned to manage what's going
inside doesn't matter how much abundance
they have they're still unhappy we've
all seen people that great comedians
that have killed themselves and it's
like they had everything except they
didn't Master what's going on here and
here you've got to take responsibility
for the energy that you allow in your
life I want you to fend off negativity
as much as humanly possible you know we
know so much more about the brain than
we did just 20 years ago Neuroscience
has taught us incredible things like
that our brains are continuously shaped
by our thoughts and our experiences and
you know this to be true negativity is
one of the most toxic forces on the
planet it's toxic for your brain for
your nervous system and for your ability
to stay motivated do me this favor do
not solicit or listen to the opinions of
people who are notorious for just being
Debbie downers the one mistake that I've
seen people make consistently is they
almost habitually talk to the exact
person who is the most likely to shoot
them down and make them feel like so
don't do that and here's another key I
want you to always consider the source
meaning don't put a lot of stock into
other people's opinions unless they're
actually out there consistently taking
risks and being brave and actually
making things happen I mean if you think
about it let's say you wanted to climb
Mount Everest would you ever take advice
from someone who's never even attempted
the summit no of course not that would
be crazy so don't take advice from
anyone unless you really think it
through most people most Champions do
not have something that you do not have
they lack something that you have for a
champion in the Physical Realm a lot of
times it's they don't have an off switch
they just keep going and so to the same
degree you probably do things every
single day that you should not be doing
and so what I want to introduce to you
is a concept of the anti-routine as the
most productive routine that is humanly
possible for you to accomplish what you
want number one is obviously just
shifting the perspective of I need to do
more things and I need to add more
things to my routine when in fact you
need to stop doing things that you're
currently doing all that remains is the
work to be done priorities mean two
things cannot be equally important when
you work on something if I spend 30
minutes on both things and I say this
one's more important than this one I can
say that but that's not reality because
I basically just said they were both
important which means neither of them
are which is why most people cannot get
done because they cannot say no you need
to have a routine of saying no an
anti-routine and that is the thing
that's going to yield those outsized
Returns on productivity you can't do two
things with different levels of
importance it's either important or it's
not important so if you say this is the
priority then it means you do not do
other things besides that thing that is
how it is a priority that is how you
literally prioritize I often say that
there's only four things that are
holding you back as a human being one is
if your vision and goal is bigger than
your self-image so if you feel you
deserve it you can have this vision and
goal and be excited about and motivate
about it you will not do what it takes
to achieve too if you have limiting
beliefs your limiting beliefs will drive
your behavior three fear fear of being
embarrassed to shame ridicule to judge
if you're a failure fear of
disappointment and the fourth one by the
way is you're lacking the knowledge and
skill required so that actually sets up
a self-doubt trigger which activates the
Frankenstein brain which caused you to
lose motivation but most people people
prefer to master disappointment and
comfort zones instead of mastering
change so if I master disappointment I
know what I got I just have to deal with
no okay this is what I got and if I
master my comfort zone then at least
this is the devil I know versus
mastering change and we know what's
going on in our brain we know what's
happening neurologically biologically
emotionally physically and all of that
is a skill why not just Master change
why not become an adaptationist right
now in the time that you need it the
most in the world if you don't then
you're just going to keep repeating the
same patterns so Master change now and
make that one of your core competencies
and then your master your life you're
around people that say Hey money won't
make you happy I'm with you it ain't
gonna make you happy but it'll buy a
nice Villa
can bring your kids and some support and
some staff the last thing I'm going to
tell you is that money matters and you
got to get your money right don't waste
it don't lose it use it use it to make
yourself better if you have a business
use it to make yourself better and the
business better hire employees use it to
make yourself better the business better
to hire employees make them better and
then add more employees and then use it
to Market your company Market yourself
to reach new connections use money to go
out and meet the people that dream
bigger than you do and that have done
all these things I'm telling you which
is they're not wasting the weekends and
they're paying the price I promise you
you'll end up with a life it'll be
beyond anything you can dream or imagine
I'm telling you AI is the opportunity
that you've been waiting for but you
have to make a move given how much AI
has already altered our systems over the
next few years I'm expecting it to
majorly accelerate our ability to test
and learn not just here in society and
whoever learns the fastest is going to
win this is all happening in playing
Insight everyone's talking about AI I
know this isn't the first time you're
hearing about it but to take advantage
of this moment I need you to do three
Simple Things One reframe your thinking
around AI don't see it as the enemy see
it as a tool it really is a phenomenal
tool you're not going to be replaced by
AI at least not yet you're going to be
replaced by a human using AI so please
be that human that's replacing other
people to do that you need to to figure
out how AI is going to disrupt you face
it head on don't run don't hide identify
your vulnerabilities and three identify
all of the AI tools that are relevant to
you and master them learn absolutely
everything you can if you even for a
second think it's a good idea for Apple
and Google and Facebook to help you be
less addicted you are on the path of
losing you don't like Instagram delete
it the second we allow ourselves to let
the machines help ourselves is the
second you become more vulnerable I
believe that you want Apple to limit the
amount of time you're on Instagram for
you like you think that's what if you
want that Mazel Tov take it but like I
promise you then there's going to be the
next thing and the next thing and the
next thing social media is exposing us
it's not changing us there is no social
media brother they're empty pipes social
media doesn't make you mean social media
doesn't make you insecure you're
insecure you're me we're getting exposed
not changed we're addicted to human
interaction the reason the world exists
in a world where we've had atomic bombs
for 70 years is we like each other when
I'm addicted to social media we are
interactive creatures you're addicted to
people cool you don't want to be on
Instagram go read vote knock yourself
out this is a very fun thing for me to
watch about people don't like being held
accountable if you think money is scarce
you hoard it because you believe that no
more money will come to you
if you know money is abundant more money
will flow to you this isn't about being
wasteful doesn't it doesn't mean you
have to go and always empty your pockets
and buy a lot of dumb stuff and throw
away all your other stuff it doesn't
mean you have to waste your money
but it's switching the mindset of money
is not just some scarce thing that you
don't know how to make that you will
never have more of and so you need to
hoard every single dollar that you've
got
this is honestly something that I am
continuing to rewire myself on I
struggled a lot with money especially in
the early days of my business
um even growing up I grew up in a middle
class family my parents spent my parents
are behind me on the wall hold on there
we go this is me when I'm eight or nine
and my parents here they believed in
education a lot and they didn't have a
ton of money we weren't poor but they
spent all of their money basically on
putting the three of us kids I have two
sisters through private school so any
money that they made basically poured
into our education
and as a result we didn't have you know
money for other things and
um where my friends at these fancy
schools were getting you know BMWs for
their 16th birthday so they can go off
and drive uh you know I didn't get any
of that and it's not what was me but
it's more I just had a scarce mentality
around money in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I was eating
the same bean salad lunch every day
because it would fill me up and wasn't
very expensive
when we celebrated a win we'd go to
McDonald's if we got a new client like
hey we sold another piece of our
software we go to McDonald's and order a
large fries and share that between the
three of us because it was cheap and we
wanted just some little way to celebrate
and
I just remember how painful it was to
feel like you have no money and you
can't buy stuff and I couldn't hang out
with my friends and I couldn't do what I
wanted to do and I think that has a
traumatic effect you know I mean maybe
that's you as well you you have a
scarcity mindset around money that you
don't know how to make it and so
anything you've got you got to really
hold on to it and protect it
and again I'm not advocating for being
Reckless or stupid or just throwing
money away be smart about how you're
going to invest and use your money the
more important thing is developing the
mindset that you can
create money that by bringing a lot of
value to people you can make more money
you can turn it into something
so one of the things that I've done
recently that that has helped both
myself and Nina my wife is we create
what we call a care fund
and every month when we're doing our
numbers
Nina will put together how much we've
made this month how much cash flows come
in ETC and then we allocate a certain
percentage for a care fund that we have
to go off and spend
either for ourselves or for other people
and so my default is to invest invest
invest invest invest right like invest
back into the business invest into into
markets invest in the assets just invest
invest invest invest invest invest
the and that's a good that's a great
good mindset the downside of that is you
don't get to see
the impact that it can create
and so said you know what we need to
dedicate a percentage every month to go
and help somebody else and maybe it's
help ourselves you know
um on the weekend Nina bought a very
expensive purse
we went shopping about a very offensive
purse we bought a Chanel bag and
probably more expensive than she's ever
bought a bag and for me it's like oh my
gosh you can't be spend this amount of
money on a bag
but it's worth
celebrating yourself so you know what
like we earned that we did so much work
in our business you can you can go and
afford that
we've also used the money to donate the
Charities we've also used the money to
support our family and things that they
needed or wanted in their lives and it's
something that we have to spend every
month
Nina asked hey can we just save it so we
can invest more and then that leads to
more in the future like no we're already
saving other money to do that like that
has to be spent every month and so where
we have to sit this might sound crazy we
have to sit down every month and figure
out how are we going to spend this money
because my default is not to go and
spend the default is to invest or just
to save
and so doing that it doesn't have to be
a big amount of money it could it could
be a hundred bucks a month that you
force yourself to spend on making
somebody else's life better or even your
own like that thing that you would never
buy for yourself you know what I've
worked hard like I'm gonna buy it or
you're going to go buy somebody a meal
or you're gonna go and give a homeless
person a hundred dollars right like
you're gonna you're gonna do something
with it
because what it does it starts to change
your mentality around it it starts to
make you feel like
more will come
that I'm creating
and so whether it's 10 bucks 100 bucks a
thousand bucks 10 000 bucks like you
know whatever it is I'm not advocating
you go drain your bank account and just
go crazy and buy a Chanel bag you know
but allocating a certain percentage
every month
so that you can start to rewire your
beliefs around money that it's not just
super scarce so that would be step
number one right allocate some kind of
budget to helping especially others
because when you can when you help
others it just makes you feel so good
and you can help others in a lot of ways
you can help them with your time you can
help them with your expertise you can
help them you know not just give a man a
fish but teach them how to fish right
but there's there's the immediate
gratification of helping somebody buying
the coffee for the person behind you in
line or seeing somebody that you know
that that
25 bucks 100 bucks will make a big
difference and like you were able to
afford to do that
gives you the extra oomph to go off and
want to do more of it like if you know
that that 25 bucks change that person's
life imagine if you can give them 2500
bucks
but to do that you'd have to go off and
build a bigger business right so the the
core of your business needs to be
serving and helping and contributing
back and you can't afford yet to give
somebody 2500 bucks but you could if you
kept building your business and so this
gives that little extra bit of
motivation incentive right to get out
there and start to do it to allocate a
certain percentage second is to be
around people who are
who are generous be around the people
who have the mindset that you want to
have if there's a belief that you want
to adopt the fastest way to do it is to
be around the people who constantly are
screaming that belief the people who are
constantly living that belief so if you
love
my view on something great hanging
around me more often is lots of videos
you love Grant cardone's view or
garyvee's view or Oprah's view on
something the more you hang around them
and watch their content and read their
books and listen to their speeches the
more you're going to start to adopt that
same belief system
so if you want to believe that money is
not scarce then you need to be hanging
around people who believe that money is
not scarce because probably the people
in your life believe money is really
scarce and the people that I grew up
with believe that money is really scarce
the closest people around me and so it
doesn't mean you stop hanging out with
them but you need to inject new people
in even if it's just through YouTube
videos
of the people who believe the thing that
you want to believe because otherwise
you get pulled back down because your
environment has been created to keep you
where you are so if you want to change
where you are you have to change the
environment and it used to be that you
had to you have to really change you
have to go somewhere else you had to
move out you had to find a mentor to
hang out with and have coffee with
consistently now you can do it through
through YouTube I've been inspired by
tons of mentors who have never met
because of the content that I've learned
from them on YouTube
but it takes the effort and intention to
be consistently around it that this is
the belief system that you want to have
you need to create that habit for
yourself from the things that are on the
wall to the clothes that you wear to the
media that you're consuming every day be
an intentional with that to say this is
this this is the belief system that I
want to have I recognize I'm not there
yet but this is this belief system I
want to have and I want to be around the
people who believe this to their core
because their belief in that thing is
stronger than your belief against it and
whoever's more confident wins
and so when you're around the people who
believe that thing so much they will
pull you towards them to start having
that similar belief system and then
everything starts to change
I think having a scarcity mindset is
extremely limiting
I've I've lived through really intense
versions of it I still feel like I'm
coming out of it I've grown a lot
compared to where I used to be but still
have a lot a long ways to go I probably
still have things
that I'm holding on to that I shouldn't
I probably still should be more generous
than I am
um and I'm I'm working through it as
well I might just be a little bit
further ahead on the curve definitely
compared to 19 year old Evan who thought
money was the most scarce thing in the
world
when you can learn to make that rewiring
happen that's how you start to change
your life
so if you look at the people around you
look at their beliefs especially around
money
and see what do they think and then see
where they're at in their life compared
to the people who have different beliefs
around money and where they're at who
would you rather be and you could be
there you could be that person
if you start to change your beliefs your
environment start to help more people
with it start to allow the money to flow
because when you start to believe that
you can create a lot more money for
yourself
a lot of things start to change because
you made it this far in a video I want
to celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to
eliminate negativity and get the outcome
you want check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there being victimized by a circumstance
in your life literally means that that
event that circumstance that person that
condition is actually causing you to
feel emotionally